this is what police saw on january 6
2021 when they were overwhelmed by a mob
trying to overturn president donald
trump's election defeat
capitol police officer carolyn edward
was the first of many officers to be
injured there were
officers on the ground
you know
they were bleeding they were throwing up
they were you know they had
i mean i saw friends with blood all over
their faces i was slipping in people's
blood
while rioters vandalized the capital and
threatened to kill members of congress
trump was watching it all unfold on tv
from the white house
according to committee investigators
trump ignored pleas from advisers and
trapped members of congress to call off
the rioters aware of the rioters chance
to hang mike pence the president
responded with this sentiment quote
maybe our supporters have the right idea
mike pence quote deserves it
committee investigators also argued that
a trump tweet in december was the
impetus for far-right groups to plan the
insurrection showing videotaped
depositions of rioters confirming their
motives he personally asked for us to
come to d.c that day and i thought
for everything he's done for us
if this is the only thing he's going to
ask me
i'll do it all of us here today then
there was the ongoing effort led by
trump to falsely claim the election had
been stolen the committee showed video
of then attorney general bill barr
testifying that the claim was in fact a
lie i made it clear i did not agree with
the idea of saying the election was
stolen and putting out this stuff which
i told the president was [ __ ]
and
you know i didn't want to be a part of
it
investigators say trump didn't listen
but his daughter ivanka told them she
did i respect attorney general barr
so i
accepted what he said was saying
according to the committee chairman
taken as a whole the riot and the
efforts to overturn the election was
nothing short of a coup attempt a first
in american history
january 6 was the culmination of an
attempted coup
a brazen attempt
as one ride to put it shortly after
january 6
to overthrow the government
republican leaders in congress remain
the former president's defenders in fact
it is the most political
and least legitimate committee in
american history
it has used congressional subpoenas to
attack republicans
violate due process
and infringe on the political speech of
private citizens
this was just the explosive beginning to
a half dozen more public hearings
scheduled for this month their promise
to feature more testimony from former
trump aides who threatened to resign and
believe trump was too dangerous to lead
by himself in the waning days of his
presidency
heidi joe castro al jazeera washington